Mark: So, do we just start out with a big colored dick in front of us and we gotta go for this?
Wade: Woo! Oh ho ho!
Jack: This is confusing.
Bob: Why does it look like a bunch of little penises are pouring salt on us?
Jack: Fuck!
Mark: Oh, its physically based?!
You've got to physically swonk it?
Wade: Yup!
Mark: Oh fuck this shit...
Jack: KA-TOOSH
Mark: Oh fuck this shit!
Bob: Imma bogey.
Jack: It's speed based
Mark: Oh, fuck this shit
Wade: Let's watch Mark slooowly make his way
Mark: Hang on, hang on
Bob: Hey guess what everybody I got a bogey
Mark: Aww fuck this shit
Jack: They look like licorice-
Mark: Fuck you
Mark: Bap
Mark: Jesus Christ
Wade: It matters how hard you push it forward.
Mark: Yea, I get that Wade, thank you.
Mark: No, I get...
Mark: I get it
Jack: Oh shit! *laughs* whoops!
Mark: Alright
Bob: HIYEAH
Bob: Ho-ly shit!
Wade: Wow, Bob.
Jack: I don't like this.
Mark: Oh, boy...
Mark: Oh, boy
Bob: HIYEAH!
Wade: Woo hoo!
Bob:  Uh-ho.No, not like this.
Mark: No!
Wade: *weird seal noise*
Jack: This is really hard to get a feel for.
Wade: Oh, also, if you press L, your balls glow.
Mark: Why?
Mark: Why would that help anybody?
Wade: I don't know. I was just letting you know.
Mark: No!
Mark: *under his breath* okay   Bob: What's up, I made it to the end.
Jack: Triple Bogie!
Wade: Mark, what's up over here?
Mark: Fucking Jesus!
Jack: Bob, it looks like you- looks like you have tiny penis shakers with "S"s on them
Bob: I know, thats what I was saying. It looks like little dildos are sprinkling salt on me the whole time.
Bob: Just imagine the sound the sound they're making.  They're just like- Wade: I don't think that's the salt
Mark: No!
Jack: I think maybe Mark should have the salt.
Wade: Yeah, I think Mark needs the salt.
Mark: Nope
Bob: How did I get the salt on top?
Mark: Nooope.  Wade: His little fleshy sushi doesn't quite fit.
Mark: Nup I got it guys
Bob: Nuupe.
Mark: Ahhh, no.  Jack: Do we go this way?
Mark: 'Cuz at least, ya know
Mark: The one thing I can say about this game
Mark: Is that the physics seem to be accurate
Mark: So I can't exactly...
Mark: Blap!
Mark: Woah!
Bob: Hole in one! Hole in one. Hole in one. Hole in one. Wade: Wow Bob
Jack: Are you serious? Mark: Wow, bob
Jack: Back!
Bob: Get wrecked.
Mark: Dammit!
Mark: Damn fuck you.
Jack: Get your balls outta my way.
Mark:  Fuuck you
Mark: Nooo
Wade: I should've gone the other way.
Mark: I've been all about the balls today
Mark: So you can just...
Bob: I like how Wade is just-  Jack: Uh-oh uh-oh!
Mark: Fuck man
Mark: Where am I ?
Jack:  Go in go in go in go in go in-COME ON! COME OOON!
Bob: Wow..
Jack: FUCK  Mark: Ohhh
Bob: That's like hovering over the edge. *Mark quietly laughs*
Jack: I coulda farted that into the hole! *Mark laughs again*
Bob: Why didn't ya? Why didn't you give it a little- a little *fart noise*.
Jack: A little *fart noise*.
Mark: A little... a little toot
Wade: I don't think we went the best- *Jack making more fart noises*
Mark: Fuck
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Why didn't you give it a little
Mark: BAAAAAAA
Mark and Jack: AAH
Mark: AAH
Mark: There we go.
Wade: AAAH
Mark: At least it's a wide hole.
Mark: It's got some girth to it.  Bob: Yeah that's a huge hole. How'd you guys mess that up?
Mark: Fuck you, that's how.
Jack: FUCK
Jack: How'd I mess that up?
Jack: Oh hey.
Mark: I don't know, man.
Mark: HEY, YES!  Wade: NOO!
Mark: Thank you!
*Jack and Bob laugh*
Jack: Noo!
Mark: Thank you.
Mark: Oh, thank you.  Bob: No NO  Jack: Bye Bob. *laughs*
*Mark laughs*
Jack: Mr. Hole in one.
Mark: The shoe is on the other foot now.
*More weird noise from Wade*
Bob: I'm an idiot though so it's fine.
*Weird noises*
Wade: Whatever.
Mark: Thanks Wade.
Wade: You're welcome. Oh, this one's annoying, just so you know.
Mark: Is it really? Jack: HAA
Bob: Sounds annoying.
Jack: Get your fire ball away from me.
Bob: Oh hey, what's up bitches.  Wade: Oh hey.
Wade: Hey how's it going?
Mark: Ohhh boy.
Jack: Fuck fuck fuck.  Bob: I have an idea.
Bob: HAAAA
Mark: Woah, Jesus.  Bob: Oh my god! *laughing*
Jack: Where'd you go?  Wade: Where- how did you go?
Mark: Ohh nooo!
Mark: It IS annoying!
Wade: What, NO!  Mark: Oh, it is!
Jack: Stay stay stay stay STAAAY!
Mark: Fuck, holy shit.
Jack: Oh hey! *laughs*
Bob: Come on.
Wade: *high pitched* NOOO
Mark: Uh oh...
Jack: Fuck my ass.
Jack: Oh hey buddy.
Mark: Hey buddy.
Jack: Two sad balls.
No no no WHOW-OH-OH Bob.
Bob: NO NO NO NO
Mark: Wade, Wade you wait, you wait your turn Wade.
Mark: NO!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
*High pitch scream from Wade*
Mark: Oh Wade you saved me. You screwed yourself and you saved me.
Wade: Yeah I screwed myself hard.
Bob: NO NO NO NO-Jack bring me with you!
Jack: *Pterodactyl sound* No-NO-HO-HO!
Bob: Hey buddy.  Mark: Oh no.
Bob: You go first, okay? Jack: No you go first. *More screams from Wade*
Jack: After salt, after salt. *Mark laughing*
Bob: Ha ha he hu he hu
Bob: Noo!  Wade: Oh hey Bob.
Mark: Oooh boy.  Bob: Wade how's it going?
Jack: Stay stay stay you green bitch.
Mark: Wade hit him, hit him. Hit him.
Jack: If you- if any of you hits me, I'm gonna hit you in real life. NOOO! *laughter* Bob: Sto-hahahap(?)
Mark: There you go.  Jack: Finally. Jesus.
Wade: What-what the weakling shot-
Jack: It didn't even give me a shot.
Bob: Wade whatcha doin' here?  Wade: Bob-don't.
Jack: You've twenty seconds. *More Mark laughter*
Bob: I got it.
Mark: Man you guys got in there late. I think I'm starting to get the hang of this. *Bob laughs*
Mark: I think I'm really starting to get a...  Bob: Hey Mark, did you know there's a power bar?
Bob: Oh wait. That was a different time you were an idiot.
Wade: Oh!
Mark: Oh wow.
Mark: Who's an idiot now bitch! OOH YE-AH!  Jack: No no NO!
Mark: Oh yeah!  Jack: FUCK
Wade: Bo-ob
Bob: Not my fault Wade  Mark: Oh yeah. Oh that is-that's the sweet delicious taste of...tang.
Wade: I didn't hit that hard.  Jack: Retribution. *Bob laughs*
Bob: Dammit Wade. *More laughter*
Bob: You made me laugh and fucked up my shot. *More Wade screams*
Bob: *laughing* Fucking shit.
Bob: This is really, like, sensitive.  Jack: Yeah Wade's the one who's played this before like alot.
Wade: I-I've not played it a lot.
Bob: Aw, come on!  Mark: Aw, he's played it a lot. He sounds like he's played it a lot.
Bob: He does sound like he's played it a lot.  Wade: Yeah, looks like I've played it a lot too a-holes
Bob: Woo I did it!
Mark: He he heh.  Jack's You're gonna be in my description as salty dicks.
Wade: I'm in LAST place. This is bullshit...
Bob: Who's winning? Hey I'm winning!
Mark: Wait, how-how do you- ooh.
Jack: Fuck
Mark: Oh, that's kinda cool.  Bob: Hey Jack.
Jack: Hey. Bob: Don't-DON'T donnn't.
Mark: *imitating Bob* Donnn't
Bob: Oh hey I did it first try. Go team.
Mark: Oooh hole in one!
Bob: Shit son.  Mark: OOH!
Mark: Oh. Oh. Oh oh oh!
Mark: I'm starting to get a hang. OOoo! Jack: I fucking hate this game *laughter*
Jack: I'm going to be here all day!  Wade: Jack's not having a good time. *laughter*
Bob: Just whack the shit out of it Jack.
Mark:Yeah, you're doing great man.
Bob: Honestly, honestly if you hit it really hard it'll bounce off the other side back onto the top.
Jack: Will it? Will it?
Mark: Will it?  Jack: Will it?
Jack: No, that wasn't hard enough!
Bob: Which one of us has finished his hole already, I wonder. Jack: I swung hard.
Wade: *laughs* Oh man...
Jack: You guys-you guys good?
Mark: Hey Bob.
Bob: You having a fun time?
Mark: Bob I'm- I'm-I'ma close second to you in score I could catch up here.
Bob: I see. I see.  Mark: Yeah.
Wade: I'm only four behind.
Jack: Oh!  Bob: There you go!
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: You shoulda done that thing I said the whole time.
Jack: I tried but-
Mark: Yeah. His weak arms couldn't make the shot.
Bob: Do or do not. Okay motherfuckers?
Jack: There is only try wait where's the hole
Mark: Guys, where's the hole
Bob: I'm gonna watch Wade and see what happens
Mark: Yeah wade, - Jack: It's over far left- Mark: The guy thats played it alot
Jack: It's over here
Wade:Yeah so much
Jack: OHOHOH YEAH!
Bob: I'm a professional just like Markiplier Mark: Thanks man
Wade: WOOHOO!
Yeah okay shit. Bob: That was too soft.
Mark: Ohhh crest the hill but don't crest it too hard- OHH BABY!
I am amazing at this!
I am astonishingly good!
I think we I think we found something that Mark doesn't suck at
Mark: Yeah, finally.
It only took five years.
Bob: At the first few holes-
Jack: Welcome to life.
Mark: Hmmmm.
Wade: What- AHHH NO JACK!
Bob: Oh no! *Mark laughing* Why? Jack: You don't fucking blame me.
*Mark still laughing*
Jack: Okay, I got this I got this I got this. *Mark still laughing*
Fuck off Mark. MARK! *Everyone laughing*
Fuck you! Mark: AHH- Fuck you man!
Fuck you! *Jack laughing*
OHH I'm back at the top! Fuck you!
Bob; Oh shit there's a jump there. Jack: Oh shit.
Bob: Ah shit. Jack: If it's any constellation I did not do myself any favour
Mark: That's not constellation at all!
I was in prime position!
Bob: NO! Mark: You were full of dick bags!
Hey, hi Jack. Jack: Hey if you could get your payback.
Bob: OH NO! *Mark laughing*
Wade: Bye Bob! Bob: God damn it Jack: Oh shit.
*Mark laughing* Mark: Ah damn it.
Jack: Oh I broke it! Bob: Oh! Did I hit someone?
aww fuck
???
????
Yayyyyyyyyy i did it
Mark:  Ohh, yay!
Wade:Oh you guys said,Par
Mark:I'm in The drink.
Mark:Oh boy.
Wade:How the hell Do we get over there?
Mark:Oh! So clo-o-o-o-o-o-ose.
Jack: OH! Oh Nooooooo.
Mark:Nooooooooo.
Jack:Do we actually have To bounce themselvs in?
Mark:Oooooooh.
Mark:Hey Guys! I did it, Why cant you Do it Also?
Jack:They dont really Want to, Thats why.
Mark:Its so rare That im on this side Of the fence,Like.
Wade:BEEEEEEEP!!!!
Mark:Uhhh,Joker is that you??
Mark:BEEEEHEEP
Wade:PLEASE! PLEASE!!!
Bob:This is really funny,Even though i suck at it its still damn Funny.
Wade:WHY IS THAT A WEAKLING SHOT?!
Wade:OH GOOD,IM OVER HERE!!
Wade:the Hell do i do NOW!?!
Jack:Fuuuuck.
Wade:WHY TIME RAN OUT!?!?!?!!!